aura donc duré 24 heures la rébellion
armée de yefghani Prigogine contre
Moscou alors que c'est troupes se
rapprochaient de la capitale russe le
chef du groupe paramilitaire Wagner a
annoncé avoir ordonné à ses hommes de
retourner dans leur base pour éviter je
cite un bain de sang quelques heures
plutôt il annonçait vouloir renverser
l'état-major russe il déclarait ses
comparé de Rostov dans le sud de la
Russie les mercenaires vont donc
rebrousser chemin après une médiation
proposée par la Biélorussie d'Alexandre
lucaschenko on écoute eviani Prigogine
il voulait dissoudre la compagnie privée
Wagner
le 23 juin nous sommes partis pour la
marche de la justice
brachly en 24 heures nous avons parcouru
tout ce chemin jusqu'à 200 km de Moscou
oui
n'avons pas versé une seule goutte du
sang de nos combattants
le moment est venu
du sang pourrait être versé
c'est pourquoi comprenant la
responsabilité que du sang russe puisse
être versé d'un des côtés
font demi-tour dans l'autre sens et
regagne leur camp de base temporaire
selon le plan
et pour mieux comprendre ce qui s'est
joué en Russie ces dernières 24 heures
on va plus loin avec vous Bruno Daru
bonsoir à vous c'est votre chroniqueur
international comment analyser cette
volte-face totalement inattendue du chef
de Wagner quel bilan tiré de ces
dernières 24 heures alors écoutez les
oui les 24 heures qui viennent de
s'écouler ont été absolument incroyables
puisqu'on a vu donc cette ministre
Wagner qui était encore en Ukraine hier
qui affirme d'ailleurs avoir été
bombardée par l'armée russe et c'est ça
qui a provoqué notamment la fureur de
yefghani pregoji n'était-il ça sa
décision de passer à l'acte donc il est
passé à l'acte il est allé donc de
l'autre côté de la frontière à Rostov
sur le don s'emparer de la ville au
petit matin
ce samedi matin sans couperrir
visiblement il n'y a pas eu vraiment de
résistance donc ça c'est un premier
point d'interrogation parce qu'il faut
savoir que Rostov sur le don c'est quand
même le QG opérationnel des Russes pour
les opérations en Ukraine donc que la
milice Wagner pardon qui était juste
juste là avec qui tu es Barbou tu étais
juste là traverse la frontière et
s'empare sans conférer de Rostov sur le
don premier point d'interrogation
peut-être pour cette idée de trouver le
chef d'état-major qu'ils construit
Valérie garracimov mais il n'était pas
là il est tombé quand même sur le
vice-piedistre de la défense et ensuite
il y a cette remontée alors peut-être
pas tout de Rosto sur le don je pense
qu'il y avait déjà des d'autres unités
des millise Wagner un peu plus haut dans
le pays mais en tout cas voilà cette
montée vers Moscou un peu comme la
Marche sur Rome de Mussolini en 1922 et
donc Vladimir Poutine qui s'adresse très
solennellement à la nation qui parle de
trahison de coup d'État du FSB les
services secrets qui vont lancer une
enquête contre ce traître bref la
dramaturgie est vraiment très forte les
chefs d'états vous allez en parler mais
chef d'État étranger se mobilise
évidemment parce que on se dit que
peut-être qu'on va assister à un grand
basculement au sein du pouvoir russe et
puis voilà tout s'arrête à 200 km de
Moscou suite à une médiation
d'Alexander locash and Co le président
biélorus à la fois vassal de Vladimir
Poutine mes proches quand même et qui
connaît Afghani pregojin et qui donc
négocie tout ce qu'on en sait d'ailleurs
c'est le fait que finalement il y a
gagné prigogne décide de ne pas marcher
sur Moscou et ordonne à cette troupe de
faire demi-tour et ordonne à ses troupes
qui étaient encore à Rostov sur le don à
faire leur paquetage et à rentrer dans
leur baraquement ce qu'on ne sait pas
Nina c'est ce qui a été vraiment négocié
parce qu'il faut rappeler que il y avait
gagné Prigogine disait je fais pas un
coup d'État je fais une marche pour la
justice et très certainement pour éviter
d'obéir à ce qu'avait décidé
shoegu le ministre de la Défense
c'est-à-dire qu'à partir du 1er juillet
dans quelques jours donc toutes les
milices reviennent sous le contrôle du
ministère de la Défense et il y avait
gagné Prigogine a dit il n'en est pas
question alors est-ce qu'il a obtenu le
fait de continuer avoir la main mise sur
sa milice Wagner très puissante et avec
beaucoup d'argent aussi et qu'il reste
indépendant et autonome c'est une
première hypothèse il demandait
également par cette marche pour la
justice comme il l'appelle si on
comprend bien à la tête de Monsieur
shohugo et celle du chef d'état-major
guerre simov est-ce qu'il a obtenu ça ce
sera à voir mais ce serait quand même
très étonnant de la part de Vladimir
Poutine d'accord des salées pour le
moment ce sont des hypothèses on ne sait
pas vraiment ce qu'il y avait dans la
négociation